I think he's a little off I think cuz
well they see pictures of your donors on
Facebook and whatnot
yeah okay cuz every time you take a
glance yeah he take a glance at
somebody's Instagram right yeah and you
need to go a little dive into their life
what is his life like right your your
wife looks very pretty and intelligent
and normal your kids look so grounded
and no I've never talked to them just
okay but just based on what I see it's
like you have a great family life you
look like a great dad I mean I saw a
photo of you I think you guys are higher
or something
you're with other Asians in the photo I
think cuz much my friend sandy who told
me out some sunglasses
yeah and you just look like you have
this really nice life and coming from
where I know where you came from which
is stand up your end um you partied a
lot in college don't party pretty hard I
know you do yeah but I just feel like
you've really called off a good life for
yourself do I'm the luckiest guy you'll
ever meet in the world i but but but
here's the thing that sucks is that I a
little bit of my career to have a
regular life so like I don't really call
him for spots that often at the store if
I'm working on something I will like I
look at it like tonight well tonight I
was doing this but we had a dinner party
with friends we went to had our kids on
Meetup and then the kids stayed then we
went to this bar and had barbecue and
then walked back and like that's kind of
how I like to spend my Monday Tuesday
Wednesday as opposed to the store where
it's just me and then I'm working on
material and then I wake up late you
know so like I kind of like being I like
being a dad I really like being but you
know what's so funny because here's a
guy talking you're talking to a guy who
was there every night I'm always I
respect that like I wish I had that now
I'll tell you okay you tell me why cuz
Kirk Fox and I were sitting in the back
the other night we're there Kirk and I
are there every night
Rick Ingraham - yeah every night and you
know and we don't see you guys alright
cuz you guys have lives right and have a
great life with my beautiful great yeah
I have a great life but my point is is
that we got we losers
you know and we're like
maybe kind of but I'll tell you the
opposite side that is me and Segura
right Segura is not there every night
killing it but no you because when you
guys are gonna show up you're it's like
mythological creatures and like oh my
god they came to visit from that like
with the great the great heavens of
comedy no but we both go up there and go
[ __ ] like I wish we were hustling I wish
we were up here every night I wish we
were like like Rogen's up there every
night [ __ ] Ari would be up there
every night you know Joey Diaz is up to
every night you're up there of you night
like Kirk Fox up there every night
[ __ ] Michael Casas up there every
night a [ __ ] Jeselnik there's so many
guys that we get it and then with all of
us we're like we're like I wish we were
hustling the way that we are but then
you think it's it's a hard balance
trying to be like a regular person and
then also be a stand-up comedian
how ironic that you say that because um
because you put segura
@v I feel like you and suger are in the
same category I feel like you guys right
now especially in 2018 are the top guys
oh yeah Tommy is I'm not I'm not even
remotely close oh you are no I'll tell
you how I tell you how you know I'll
tell you why okay I'll tell you why okay
to get me and Chris D'Elia to show up on
a Monday to do your cooking show I was
surprised by that
no but you let me just say this or I
know you said cuz him and I were an
instant yes right and and when I showed
up Chris had already been there for like
30 minutes waiting to do it and Chris is
a busy guy and he's also you know he's
just that guy he's busy yeah but and I'm
kind of busy lately right and for us to
go to drop things and go we have to do
it right means that there's something
going on with you that's special that is
the best compliment I've ever gotten in
this entire business in my life because
like to get Bryan Callen and Brendan
Schaub to do it as well is special so
what I'm saying is is that I guarantee
you that you're one of the top guys
right now that is the best compliment
I've ever gotten in my in this business
because it's it's an applicable comment
compliment where you go because I did
when they said who you
to get and I was like well I don't know
like I was like I said a bunch of names
and they're like what about Thalia and
Bobby Lee and I was like but yeah but I
don't think we're ever gonna get them
and then they were like they're
available Monday I was like are you
serious and they're like I was blown the
[ __ ] away because that was one of the
best episodes we've shot
god bless you that was one of the
funniest God bless you and take care no
and I want to say this I want to say
this to you Bert yeah it's just that I
mean a couple of times I've been I've
been to all things comedy I said how do
I get into Brooks thing you know like
he's busy this and that so I was waiting
I was waiting on the wing I also give
you a [ __ ] you think that was a
compliment one of the puffy lips [ __ ]
Reese [ __ ] not really your [ __ ] puffy
lips are [ __ ] like a [ __ ] I said he
said it all right I wrote that one down
yeah you're someone that's been pretty
or someone that's been killing it for
like like I'm gonna say 15 years oh my
god you have you don't even know what
you're talking about right now dude I do
you don't know what my life I'm gonna
say this right now bro and I've said
this before and I'll say it again my
life didn't change and I wasn't in the
game until I met this lady no way tell
me this lady right here changed my whole
career in so many in some way that part
that we said he was so good at yeah
here's the thing if you don't know you
don't know this all right I haven't
written a joke in probably six years
really yeah really that's not true I do
maybe five new jokes yeah thank you
thank you so much number two I play
probably about twelve hours of video
games a day maybe more maybe more I
don't eat well when I get auditions or I
get offered things I usually say no
because of laziness and fear and when I
met her I was at the bottom I couldn't
get anything going I didn't have I
remember a time
he was on his hands and knees praying
that he would get the part of that one
guys like non-existent show remember
that we were mr. robot no not mr. robot
you and a friend of yours yeah remember
from MADtv you were like I hope we get
this oh yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah so there was a I was at the
competition winner and this English guy
comes up to me that guy yeah yeah and he
goes I'm not gonna say his name I love
him he's very funny I'll tell you later
okay cuz I don't know I don't want me to
feel bad if he's listening he goes hello
I'm doing this pilot and I go what is it
just I'm just doing my own independent
pilot and and Troy Troy Miller is doing
it and I and I got into my heads and
he's like oh please let me do it and it
wasn't even a network or studio he was
just Troy and him were just doing it on
their own and then like me showing up
and like he was taking like auditioning
and trying to get it yeah it was it was
it was basically at the end of the day
like a YouTube and I was like waiting in
line and begging to get on that I
remember that and you're like looking at
me like no you're probably you know me
and I'm like that's all I can get and
then like I did all I liked 8080 Chelsea
Lately is just so that could get people
in the rooms yeah well you know I was
not I mean I Thank You Chelsea for the
opportunity but I wasn't and when I met
her she's just messy kept saying you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] I so bizarre how you
perceive yourself I proceeded myself in
a poor light and but like I have never
perceived you as anything other than and
when you go I haven't written a joke in
six years part of me goes well you
should just write down what you're
saying on stage in the store because all
of that like that's the way I write is I
just go up and I I go [ __ ] nuts on
stage and I try to write on stage yeah
yeah but your improv ZAR better than the
jokes I've written so like I watch you I
sit back and watch you and I got right
here Jesus man but then but it's so
funny that you say that that that is
your reality because I've seen the
opposite side of you I always go
like the new show you're on right now
the in between us or putting up together
I saw that no one's like of course
Bobby's in that like a like of course
you know the way you'd say that about
like of course Tigers in the lead you
know like a mass and the run
[Music]